Знову радий вітати вас.
У нас урок фізики для 1О класу,
а мене звати Сергій Колебошин!
Ми з вами ретельно вивчили тему,
яка пов’язана з властивостями рідини.
Ми знаємо, що таке поверхневий натяг,
ми знаємо, що таке змочування,
ми знаємо, що таке капілярні явища
(ми про це говорили останні два уроки).
Саме час навчитися
розв’язувати задачі на цю тему.
Тим паче, розв’язуючи
декілька задач, ми з вами
запишемо ще деякі формули, які допоможуть
нам зрозуміти певні явища з теми уроку.
Тему уроку можна записати у
ваших зошитах, ви бачите її на дошці.
Перш ніж ми почнемо, я хотів
би, щоб ви відкрили ваші зошити,
відкрили підручники і згадали
основні теоретичні відомості:
що таке коефіцієнт поверхневого натягу,
як розрахувати силу поверхневого натягу,
як розрахувати надлишкову потенціальну
енергію або поверхневу енергію,
як знайти висоту підняття рідини
по капіляру, якщо змочування і,
відповідно, якщо незмочування,
то зворотній процес.
Якщо вам необхідний час для того,
щоб згадати, ставте плеєр на паузу,
згадуйте і потім будемо
продовжувати працювати.
Ми переходимо до умови першої задачі.
Тобто, в нас є якась краплина, давайте
намалюємо, щоб далі було легше міркувати.
Це ситуація 1.
У нас є якась краплина
(давайте блакитним кольором),
вона, умовно, велика, з радіусом R.
Ми хотіли б розбити
її (це буде ситуація 2)
на вісім маленьких краплинок.
Всього їх вісім цих краплинок, радіусом r.
Перш ніж ми будемо записувати
коротку умову, давайте поміркуємо,
а чому нам потрібно
виконувати якусь роботу?
Проти чого виконується робота?
Проти певних сил.
Які сили не бажають, щоб у
нас відбулося таке роз’єднання?
Звичайно, що це сили поверхневого
натягу. Чому? Що змінилося?
Чи змінюється коефіцієнт
поверхневого натягу?
Ні, в нас як була краплина
води, так і лишається вода.
Але що в нас змінилося?
У нас збільшилася (в другому випадку)
площа поверхні, сумарна площа поверхні.
Сумарна площа поверхні
восьми краплин більша,
ніж площа поверхні однієї краплини.
Ми знаємо, що рідина, умовно
кажучи (побутовою мовою)
не хоче, щоб у неї
збільшувалася площа поверхні.
Якраз проти цього і буде виконуватися
робота з подолання цих сил.
Тож переходимо до запису короткої умови.
Що нам дано?
Дивимось, перше, що ми знаємо –
радіус краплини (такої «материнської»
краплини) – цієї краплини.
Я його позначив R (2 мм.).
Здавалося б, більше
нічого немає, але це не так.
Ми знаємо, яка це рідина,
а отже, ми можемо записати
характеристику цієї рідини.
Яка характеристика в контексті
умови задачі для нас важлива?
Для нас важлива питома поверхнева енергія,
тобто, коефіцієнт поверхневого натягу.
Ми можемо відкрити у
себе в підручниках таблицю.
Я вже не буду цього робити
на екрані, я просто запишу:
коефіцієнт поверхневого натягу
води – 72 міліньютона на метр.
Тобто, 72 на 1О у мінус третьому ступені
(мілі- – це 1О у третьому ступені).
Треба знайти роботу.
Ми з вами вже з’ясували, що ця робота
пов’язана із зміною площі поверхні,
із зміною надлишкової потенціальної
енергії, яка є в молекул біля поверхні.
Давайте згадаємо, чому дорівнює
ця надлишкова потенціальна енергія?
У першому випадку (W поверхневе 1)
поверхнева енергія (ми її по-іншому
називали) дорівнює сігма на S1,
де S1 – це площа поверхні.
Площа поверхні – це важливо!
У другому випадку,
відповідно, це сігма на S2.
Робота це і буде зміна
цієї потенціальної енергії.
Тобто, щоб знайти роботу, потрібно
знайти зміну потенціальної енергії
(теорема про зміну потенціальної енергії).
Ми можемо з вами записати, що робота
(А) – це зміна потенціальної енергії.
Ми зараз рахуємо за модулем,
ми розуміємо, що це робота,
яку над системою треба виконати
Це буде сігма на зміну площини,
бо коефіцієнт поверхневого
натягу в нас не змінюється
(як була вода, так і лишається вода).
Тобто, це:
Друзі фізика в нас у
цій задачі закінчилася.
Ми розуміємо, проти чого
ця робота виконується,
ми розуміємо, як її розрахувати,
зараз починається геометрія.
Нам просто потрібно порахувати,
наскільки більша сумарна площа
поверхні восьми краплин,
у порівнянні з однією краплиною.
З точки зору геометрії, вісім
сфер і одна велика сфера.
Тож давайте згадаємо, чому
дорівнює площа поверхні сфери.
Якщо ви цього не пам’ятаєте,
візьміть підручник з геометрії
і візьміть цю формулу.
Якщо ви не стикалися з цією
формулою, то запишіть її разом зі мною,
вона вам знадобиться в багатьох задачах.
Тож, площа поверхні сфери
радіусом R, я напишу для випадку S1
Це площа поверхні сфери.
Чому дорівнює загальна площа S2 (сумарна
площа поверхні цих восьми краплин)?
Звичайно, що це буде, давайте запишемо:
S2=8 (бо краплин вісім)
помножити на 4 Пі r в квадраті,
де r – радіус маленької краплини.
Здавалося б, що все добре, ми можемо
взяти, все порахувати, але в нас немає r.
Звідки ми його знайдемо?
В умові задачі у нас тільки
радіус великої краплини.
Що з цим робити?
Дуже просто, давайте міркувати:
ця краплина
і ці вісім краплин – одна й та сама вода,
тобто, не змінилася сумарна
маса води, яка була тут
і яка була тут.
До речі, якщо є бажання, можете
порахувати масу цієї краплини,
якщо ви знаєте, що це вода,
тобто, густину води і радіус.
Однак завдання не в цьому.
Якщо не змінюється маса, а густина та сама
(це і це – вода), то не змінюється об’єм.
Об’єм цієї краплини і об’єм
цих краплин такий самий.
Площа збільшилася – проти цього ми
виконуємо роботу, а об’єм не змінився.
Давайте використаємо цей факт і
згадаємо, як порахувати об’єм кулі –
це теж геометрія.
Ось тут фізика закінчилася.
Ну що ж, чому дорівнює об’єм?
Давайте запишемо перше:
V2=V1 – об’єми не змінилися.
Чому дорівнює об’єм кулі?
Якщо ви не знаєте цю формулу, вона
дуже проста: об’м кулі (V1) це буде
Відповідно, V2 (сумарний
об’єм цих восьми крапель) –
Ми можемо прирівняти ці два
вирази і отримати звідси вираз для r.
Давайте це зробимо.
Тож, записуємо, чому дорівнює
радіус маленької краплинки.
Я вам раджу зробити це самостійно.
Ми працюємо…
r куб – це вісім кубів маленького радіусу.
Як знайти r – кубічний
корінь з восьми це скільки?
Це 2 ( 2 в кубі – це 8).
Ми матимемо, що маленький
радіус – це половина великого радіусу.
У нас все є для того,
щоб порахувати цю роботу.
Можна робити в два способи:
перший спосіб «лобовий» –
порахувати радіус, знайти
площу і так далі, і так далі.
Я раджу вам отримувати кінцеву формулу
одразу для роботи і з нею вже працювати.
Цей підхід більш ефективний
у багатьох задачах,
коли якась величина
скорочується в самому кінці.
Тож, чому буде дорівнювати робота?
Якою буде наша кінцева формула?
Записуємо.
Отже, робота: сігма…
S2 це що таке?
Вісім на 4 Піr квадрат.
Дивіться, r квадрат дорівнює
половині великого радіусу в квадраті.
r квадрат на 4.
В знаменнику 4 і тут 8,
тобто, в нас буде тут 2.
Ми отримаємо: 2 * 4= 8 Пі R квадрат,
а r – S1 ми знаємо (4 ПіR квадрат).
Якщо відняти, то ми
отримаємо кінцеву формулу,
я її навіть червоним маркером напишу.
Лишаються тільки розрахунки.
Знову раджу ставити на паузу,
робити розрахунки самостійно,
оскільки тут є величини не в
системі СІ (не в міжнародній системі).
Якщо вам це важко, давайте подивимося,
яка величина буде в мене і порівняємо.
Радіус теж в міліметрах:
2 в квадраті – це 4,
мілі- – 1О у мінус третьому,
в квадраті – це 1О у мінус шостому.
Дивіться, по-перше, розмірність:
метр і метр квадратний скорочуються.
Ньютон помножити на метр – це
якраз одиниця роботи, це джоуль.
Якщо це порахувати, то ми
отримаємо, що робота дорівнює…
Задачу розв’язано.
Запишіть відповідь, трохи відпочиньте
і переходимо до умови другої задачі.
Тож, умова другої задачі.
Дивимось на екран!
Тобто, коефіцієнт поверхневого натягу.
Давайте, перш ніж будемо
виконувати цю задачу,
подивимось на аналогічну
демонстрацію, на аналогічний експеримент
і зрозуміємо, чому нам
потрібні додаткові зусилля,
у порівнянні з тим, якби ми
піднімали це кільце просто у повітрі.
Тож, демонстрація.
Дивіться,
в мене тут мильний розчин.
Роль кільця буде
виконувати скляна пластинка.
Фізика явищ така сама, але там
буде (у випадку з кільцем) один нюанс,
який ми з вами використаємо
під час розв’язування.
Також динамометр –
прилад для вимірювання сили.
Давайте подивимося чому будуть
дорівнювати покази динамометру в повітрі.
Дивимось, покази динамометра
близько 0,14-0,15 ньютонів –
ви це можете побачити
тут, на шкалі динамометра.
Тепер опустимо до мильного розчину.
Думаю, життєвий досвід вам вже підказує,
чи зміниться сила, яка
мені необхідна для того,
щоб відірвати це кільце
від поверхні рідини,
чи вона буде так само 0,14.
Уважно дивіться на покази динамометра.
Ви бачите, що вони більші за 0,14.
Коли я відірвав, вони повертаються
до попереднього значення.
Значить, якась додаткова сила заважає
нам піднімати цю скляну пластинку
або те кільце, яке у
нас буде в умові задачі.
Що це за сила ми вже знаємо.
Звичайно, що це сила поверхневого натягу.
Адже ми намагаємося
збільшити площу поверхні рідини
і рідина цього, умовно кажучи, не хоче.
Розуміючи фізику явища, давайте
перейдемо до, власне, цієї задачі.
Тож, коротка умова задачі. Що нам дано?
Перше – ми знаємо радіус кільця.
Давайте запишемо: R=7,8 см.
Маса кільця – 7 гр.
Необхідно прикласти зусилля
0,11 ньютонів – це сила (F).
F=0,11 Н.
Також ми знаємо, що це мильний розчин.
Власне, коефіцієнт поверхневого
натягу мильного розчину нам треба знайти.
Давайте запишемо, що треба знайти – сігма.
Не буде чесним, якщо ви
візьмете таблицю і подивитеся.
Це якраз експеримент,
який допомагає знайти
коефіцієнт поверхневого натягу
мильного розчину або іншої рідини.
Є навіть така лабораторна
робота в профільних класах
із знаходження коефіцієнта
поверхневого натягу
за допомогою подібних експериментів.
Давайте намалюємо,
що відбувається в задачі.
Отже, в нас є якась рідина,
і я умовно намалюю кільце,
бік цього кільця, якщо ми
дивимось вперед, фронтально.
Ось це кільце,
воно далі якось туди йде.
Отак от воно лежить.
Що відбувається, коли
ми тягнемо кільце вгору?
Змочування, площа поверхні збільшується,
відповідно, з’являються
сили поверхневого натягу,
які бажали б зменшити цю площу.
Давайте намалюємо, які сили діють на
ділянку кільця або, власне, на все кільце.
Тож, вниз напрямлена у нас, як завжди,
сила тяжіння (mg).
Куди напрямлені сили поверхневого натягу?
Здається, що можна одразу намалювати
вниз, бо ми знаємо, що вони нам заважають,
але давайте це покажемо.
Насправді, вони напрямлені
якимось таким чином – по дотичній.
F поверхневого натягу…
F поверхневого натягу.
Якщо ми подивимось на все кільце…
Давайте намалюємо,
умовно кажучи, все кільце.
Ось так от…
Ось воно лежить, на
поверхні мильного розчину.
То ці сили будуть напрямлені тут отак,
а з цього боку – так.
Далі: тут – якось сюди,
з цього боку – сюди.
Сюди, сюди і так далі.
Всюди ось так от.
Куди буде напрямлена рівнодійна цих сил?
Це нескладно знайти, дивіться,
навіть по цих двох силах.
Зрозуміло, що рівнодійна
буде напрямлена вниз.
Тому рівнодійна всіх
сил поверхневого натягу,
які діють на всі ділянки
цього кільця, напрямлена вниз.
Я малюю загальну рівнодійну
силу поверхневого натягу.
Теж, умовно, з центру.
F поверхневого натягу – це загальна
вже сила, яка діє на все кільце.
Коли ми тягнемо кільце вгору,
ми виконуємо роботу проти цих сил,
тобто, ми маємо прикласти
силу, яка напрямлена вгору.
Малюємо…
Це якраз ця сила F.
Давайте запишемо другий закон Ньютона.
Саме другий закон Ньютона
допоможе нам знайти величину сігма,
бо де вона захована ця сігма?
Вона захована, згадайте формулу
для сили поверхневого натягу,
якраз в цій силі, яку я
червоним маркером намалював.
Саме там вона прихована.
Тож, записуємо другий закон Ньютона:
сума всіх сил дорівнює нулеві.
Ми рівномірно піднімаємо,
не з прискоренням.
Тож, запишемо.
Звертаю вашу увагу, три сили на кільце.
Ці сили, ці вектори були
нам необхідні для того,
щоб знайти куди напрямлена рівнодійна.
Тобто, це рівнодійна всіх цих сил.
Три сили!
Це не додаткові сили.
Сума всіх сил – нуль.
Проекція на вертикальну вісь,
наприклад, ми її направимо вгору,
в проекції це буде із плюсом…
Фактично, у нас є все, щоб
знайти силу поверхневого натягу,
а знаючи силу поверхневого натягу,
знайти коефіцієнт поверхневого натягу.
Давайте запишемо чому дорівнює
сила поверхневого натягу, яка формула.
F поверхневого натягу, я нагадаю,
це сігма (коефіцієнт поверхневого
натягу – те, що ми з вами шукаємо)
помножити на l,
де l – довжина границі.
Тут є нюанс, досить часто роблять помилку,
бо вважають, що довжина
границі – це довжина кола.
Друзі, але у нас сказано, що є кільце.
Скільки там границь, фактично?
Зовнішня і внутрішня.
Кільце є тонким, тому радіуси
можна вважати однаковими,
і ми маємо з вами врахувати,
що в нас є дві границі.
Тобто, це сігма на 2 (дві довжини кола).
Чому дорівнює довжина кола?
Ви маєте пам’ятати – 2 ПіR.
Радіус ми позначили великою літерою.
Ось ця двійка дуже важлива,
бо досить часто роблять помилку,
коли не враховують цей факт.
Далі все дуже просто: підставляємо цю
формулу сюди і, звідси, знайдемо сігму.
Працюємо…
Я традиційно раджу вам робити це
самостійно, але я теж маю це зробити.
Лишається останній крок –
виразити звідси сігму.
Теж пауза, працюєте самостійно.
Я записую чому буде дорівнювати сігма.
Лишаються тільки розрахунки.
Теж робіть самостійно,
не забувайте про переведення
у міжнародну систему одиниць,
і знаходимо, чому дорівнюватиме коефіцієнт
поверхневого натягу мильного розчину.
Я пропоную вам зробити
це повністю самостійно.
Я ж записую кінцеву відповідь.
Щось же ви маєте робити повністю
самостійно, без моєї допомоги.
Кінцева відповідь має бути наступна.
Якщо подивитись у таблицю,
це якраз буде відповідати коефіцієнту
поверхневого натягу мильного розчину.
Що ж, друзі, задача розв’язана,
експеримент ми подивилися.
Лишається третя задача.
Я нагадаю, тема уроку в нас:
«Поверхневий натяг. Капілярні явища».
Про поверхневий натяг – дві задачі,
давайте хоча б одну
розв’яжемо про капілярні явища.
Умова третьої задачі.
Переходимо до короткої умови.
Записуємо коротку умову задачі.
Що нам дано?
Ми знаємо, що у нас
радіус капіляра – 2 мм.
Ми знаємо, що це вода, ми
знаємо характеристики цієї води.
Ми знаємо густину води,
вона нам знадобиться.
Ви можете одразу
здогадатися, що нам знадобиться
і густина води, і поверхневий натяг
води, оскільки мова йде про капіляри.
Якщо ви згадаєте минулий урок,
то ми там записували висоту
підняття рідини по капіляру.
Там в нас була і густина, і радіус,
і коефіцієнт поверхневого натягу.
Ми зараз згадаємо цю формулу.
Тому я пропоную одразу
записати – густина води...
За температури 20 градусів,
якщо не йдеться про особливі умови,
будемо брати якраз такі значення.
Треба знайти тиск Лапласа,
тобто, цей надлишковий тиск,
який, фактично, і спричиняє рух
води по капіляру або іншої рідини.
Р (давайте так і писати –
Лапласа, з індексом л).
Я казав, що він зветься Лапласів тиск.
Тому його і треба знайти.
Одразу досить важко зрозуміти,
що відбувається в задачі,
тому давайте намалюємо, ще
раз, капіляр, який занурений у воду.
До речі, що буде робити вода в
ньому: підніматися чи опускатися?
Для цього у нас є одна фраза в умові,
вона нам ще двічі сьогодні
знадобиться – змочування повне.
Якщо є змочування, ми
пам’ятаємо, що вода піднімається.
Давайте намалюємо це.
У нас є якась посудина із водою
(давайте блакитним кольором – вода).
В нас є капіляр.
В ньому є підйом певний на якусь висоту h.
Основний рівень води, оцей
рівень, давайте, позначу АВ.
Це нам знадобиться. Тут теж вода.
Давайте запишемо умову
рівноваги мовою тисків.
Це ж, фактично, дві
посудини: одна в середині іншої.
Тобто, це, фактично, сполучені посудини.
Ми знаємо умову рівноваги
в сполучених посудинах:
тиски на одному рівні
мають бути однаковими.
Для капілярів це теж має виконуватися.
Тому, давайте запишемо цю умову.
Тож, на рівні АВ
що тисне на основну
воду, будемо казати так?
На неї тисне атмосфера
(Р атмосферне – ось воно).
Записую.
Р атмосферне (це з одного боку).
А тут, на рівні АВ, але
в середині капіляра?
Тут в нас, звичайно, є
атмосфера – ніхто її не скасовував.
Записую: Р атмосферне…
Що у нас ще є?
В нас є стовпчик води висотою h,
тобто, є гідростатичний
тиск (Р гідростатичне).
Формулу гідростатичного тиску ми
записували в 7 класі, ми її згадаємо.
Також у нас є цей Лапласів
тиск, який і спричиняє цей підйом
(Р Лапласа – надлишковий тиск).
Дивимось, атмосферний тиск скорочується,
і ми отримуємо дуже
цікавий висновок, друзі.
Дивіться, Р Лапласа = - Р гідростатичне.
Лапласів тиск у цьому випадку є від’ємним.
Він і піднімає туди рідину,
доки цей тиск його не компенсує.
У випадку змочування він є від’ємним.
Поміркуйте самостійно, яким
він є у випадку незмочування.
Аналогічні міркування:
запишіть, будь ласка, умову рівноваги,
умову сполучених посудин
у випадку незмочування.
Нам ця формула допоможе
знайти Лапласів тиск,
бо нам просто треба згадати,
чому дорівнює гідростатичний
тиск стовпчика води висотою h.
Це дуже просто.
Ми з вами це робили у 7
класі, запишемо і зараз.
Що це таке?
ро*g*h дуже знайома формула.
Якщо є підручник 7 класу, можете відкрити.
Густина води, прискорення
вільного падіння і висота підйому.
Тут нам знадобиться формула, яку
ми з вами вивели на минулому уроці –
формула для висоти підйому h.
Я її тут запишу, нагадаю.
Дивіться, це радіус капіляра,
а тут буде радіус кривизни.
Нам знову знадобиться фраза,
яка є в умові – змочування повне.
Якщо змочування повне, то радіус
капіляра дорівнює радіусу кривизни.
Я можу переписати її в такому вигляді.
З малою похибкою можна вважати, що
в дійсності у нас плюс-мінус така сама
ситуація (там не буде великої похибки).
Підставляємо цю висоту (h) у
формулу гідростатичного тиску
і отримаємо формулу для Лапласового тиску.
Ми отримали формулу для Лапласового тиску,
в цьому випадку – від’ємного
надлишкового тиску.
Не боюся того, що я казав,
від’ємний надлишковий тиск
(він є надлишковим, а знак у
нього від’ємний у цьому випадку).
Лишаються тільки розрахунки.
Я вам раджу, як завжди,
зробити їх самостійно.
Тут у нас все є,
навіть, бачите, густина скоротилася,
в нас є сігма, в нас є радіус.
Працюємо і знаходимо, що ми отримаємо…
Тут, подивіться, дуже цікава історія:
тут в нас сігма – міліньютон
на метр і радіус в міліметрах,
тому ми можемо мілі- і мілі- не
переводити, бо вони скоротяться,
і нам так зручніше буде працювати.
Метр на метр – це метр квадратний,
ньютон на квадратний метр –
це паскаль (одиниця тиску).
Задачу розв’язано.
Ми знайшли формулу для Лапласового тиску.
Цією формулою можна користуватися і далі.
Що ж, друзі, ми з вами
розглянули три типових задачі,
такі задачі щороку трапляються і в ЗНО.
Я чую вже дзвоник, це
означає, що цей урок закінчено,
ми дуже добре попрацювали
із властивостями рідини.
Домашнє завдання ви
побачите в описі до цього уроку.
На наступних уроках ми
перейдемо до твердих тіл.
Нагадаю, пара в нас була, рідина –
зараз, тверді тіла і поговоримо
про властивості твердих тіл.
Дякую за увагу! До побачення!